You said you have a dog.
[Chris] Yes.
What's your dog's name?
Potato.
Why did you do that?
Why did you call it Potato?
It felt like at the time
we were in London and he
looked kind of like a potato.
I can't remember, there was some in-joke
that we've actually forgotten.
And now whenever I'm in the park
people think I have Irish Tourette's.
Potato!
(Conan laughs)
Come here.
Hey!
I'm actually trying to get him.
Where is he?
Hold on.
Is he there?
I'm gonna show you because,
hey, listen, he has a
trick I'd love you to see.
Oh, I wanna see this.
Okay.
All right.
Hold on.
Potato?
Oh, come here.
Good boy.
Yeah, good boy.
Oh, Potato.
It all seems too on the nose, but this is,
I mean, this is something I
discovered that he could do
one day when I was just
watching TV, watching a show
which you'll be familiar with
and the theme tune came on
and this happened.
("The Office" theme music)
(Potato howls)
(Conan laughs)
Wait, Potato only does does that
when he hears "The Office" theme song?
"The Office" theme song.
I've no idea why.
There must be some note
in the music that like--
It's so funny because
when it first started,
Potato was looking down,
ears twitching, thinking,
and then it got to the
certain part of the song
and (imitates Potato howling).
Yeah.
Maybe there's a new,
there must be an instrument
change in there somewhere,
but it's amazing.
Wow.
Makes me so happy.
That's such a sweet trick.
That's so amazing that
you found the one show
either Potato loves or Potato can't stand.
When your theme song
comes on, he does a fart.
(Conan laughs)
(Chris chuckles)
It's quite sweet.
Like, it's just as regular.
Yeah, yeah, I'm sure that
means he really loves the show.
That's my guess.